there's this amazing moment uh last
night from Fox News where uh Laura
Ingram is ranting and raving and all of
a sudden it doesn't go well for Herschel
Walker and she kind of loses it so first
and foremost uh let's go to the moment
at uh which Laura Ingram is ranting and
raving and kind of ginning up a
conspiracy theory of some kind and then
um all of a sudden it's announced that
Herschel Walker has lost check this out
guys uh we appreciate it Bill uh stay
with us I all right sorry this is not
the right clip here is the right clip
why is it
are always the last ones to report very
suspicious isn't it Bill Hammer I mean
presumably they can't they count and
there are numbers and they count they're
more people obviously but it seems like
it kind of this is I hate to say this is
just a familiar refrain but it's a very
familiar refrain to us isn't it
suspicious election night pass to just
the midterms uh Etc I'm gonna say that
that's that's where you find the people
um that's where they live and Laura
right now we're relying on the
Associated Press to give us these
numbers and right now the Associated
Press is just given the check mark to
Raphael Warner is going back to the U.S
Senate as the winner of this runoff
against Herschel Walker right now at
50.4 percent to Walker's 49.6 Raphael
Warnock has won the runoff in Georgia
four weeks after Sinbad I just love that
as Laura Ingram is starting to go all
conspiratorial I don't know the blue
areas take longer to give us their votes
sorry Laura let me interrupt your
conspiracy to mention that Herschel
Walker has lost this race and Raphael
Warnock has won now later on in the
night
Laura Ingram is clearly very worried and
this is this really is a pleasure to
watch I wanted to start this at the 125
Mark which is here take a listen made
and yeah nothing seems to be changing
but you didn't see a lot of enthusiasm
down there of course the spending was
completely yeah it was just look at how
close it was though I mean what did we
say this was winnable
Kelly do you you want Ronald McDaniel I
like Ronald McDaniel is like a a warning
sign flashing are we just gonna oh
Laura's worried and she should be doing
the same thing all over again every
single election Kevin McCarthy won the
house he won the house yes he did and we
were out spent three to one here why no
excuse there's no excuse in Georgia for
us not to have done what Brian Kemp did
yes he's the incumbent Governor he's
very popular he's running against Stacey
Abrams but he turned out over his micro
targeting plan his Grassroots people and
I guess at Mitch McConnell's group
funded it but they did that in the last
couple of days
ago all right so Laura Ingram visibly
worried and then it gets a little tense
with kellyanne Conway she is not taking
the loss well and she's starting to take
it out on kellyanne Conway which I love
we don't Bank ballots early we're going
to keep this but we didn't we
vote earlier because that's correct not
everyone well I think a lot of people
did at the very top of the Republican
party people did but Molly Mitch
McConnell did give 11 million to the
effort that's 14 million to the effort
in Georgia
but where was the all hands on deck to
get Lindsey Graham he was there he did a
lot every Senator should have been there
every female senator but why I'm going
to ask the question tonight nobody wants
to talk about this why weren't they down
there right well part of it is Herschel
Walker was a disastrous candidate and
Republicans as it became clear that the
December 6 runoff was no longer
necessary for Democrats to control
because Democrats were going to control
the Senate either way once that became
clear
some Republicans who are marginally more
Tethered to reality realized this guy's
a humiliating candidate he can't speak
he can't think he's a hypocrite he's
going around urging women to get
abortions even though he says he's
against abortions and he's saying he's a
police officer when he's not and he's
saying you train with the FBI when he
didn't and on and on and on
why are they going to Hitch their wagon
to this horse why are they going to go
out on a limb when either way they're
not going to have control of the Senate
if Herschel Walker wins that's why they
weren't there and it was a complete and
total disaster but you know in a normal
country Walker never would have even won
a primary he was only even there because
of the atrocity that is the Republican
party so a tough night for Laura Ingram
it is what it is fortunately we are now
Beyond this Democrats will control 51-49
it gives a little bit more
you know calmness to some hypothetical
scenarios Republicans will have the
house and we're going to have an
obstruction filled two years we will
take a quick break make sure you were
subscribed on YouTube it is free we need
your subscription on YouTube you can
vote multiple times on YouTube when it
comes to elections you can't you get one
vote many people have a couple Google
accounts you can subscribe to the
YouTube channel with each and every
account it's completely legal you won't
go to jail even if you get caught
youtube.com the davidpackman show help
us get to 2 million subscribers we're
going to take a quick break and I have
so many other things to cover with you
today our sponsor real paper makes
toilet paper 100 from bamboo never from
trees meaning no deforestation
sustainability and climate change can be
a tricky topic for people of all ages it
can be particularly challenging to talk
about with kids and real paper recently
launched the little lemurs box a 24 pack
of their bamboo toilet paper with a
beautifully Illustrated Kids book that
tells an exciting story of
sustainability the box is designed to
spark creativity and kids create an
opportunity to talk about deforestation
plastic pollution in a way that's light
and easy and with the holidays here the
book makes a great gift for a little one
on your list real papers little lemurs
box and all of the other products are
available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or just simple one-time
purchases on their website all orders
are conveniently delivered to your door
with free shipping and this is the best
part 100 recyclable plastic free
packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order order and free
shipping the link is down below